web assembly write applications for the
web and languages other than javascript
imagine a world where you could build
software with c plus plus rust python go
or even cobalt then deliver that
software to the end user in a web
browser without any installation
and near native performance that world
became a reality in december 2019
when webassembly became an official w3c
standard
it includes a low-level language similar
to assembly that can be represented with
text
then converted to a binary format that
runs on all modern browsers
however you won't actually write this
code directly but rather use it as a
compilation target
for programs written in other languages
for example you might build a game with
unity and c-sharp
then compile it to webassembly where it
can be delivered in the browser
now it's important to note that it's not
intended to replace javascript
in fact the two work well together side
by side figma for example
uses react.js for its outer ui then on
the inside you have a high performance c
plus plus design tool that feels just as
fast as native software
as a developer there are many different
ways you can build a webassembly app
with many more under development one of
the most popular tools is mscriptin
which can convert a c
or c plus plus program to webassembly as
it did by bringing autocad to the web
which is a 30 year old codebase
no way one of the best ways to get
started is with assembly script which is
a language that looks like typescript
but compiles to webassembly we can
easily start a new assembly script
project
using node.js and npm then we'll write
our first webassembly module
in the index ts file unlike javascript a
dynamic interpreted language
webassembly is a static compiled
language with strict type guarantees
for example our code can't use the any
type when it comes to numbers
we need to specify a 32-bit integer or a
64-bit floating point
in addition we can't use dynamic objects
instead we use maps where we can
strongly type the key value pairs once
we're happy with our code we can then
compile it down to a binary which is a
file that ends in
wasm we can now run this binary in the
browser open an html page
and then use the webassembly api to
instantiate streaming
simply fetch the binary and when the
promise resolves do something with it
this has been webassembly in 100 seconds
if you want to see a more in-depth video
on this topic
please let me know in the comments and
make sure to subscribe and hit the like
button
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one